What I have to do is I have to check all my cases where I have recursion
and eliminate any possibility for infinite recursion.
Now, there are two possibilities in the star function and the plus function.
Those are the two cases where regular expressions have recursion.
But now star I defined in terms of plus,
so all that's left is to fix plus to not have an infinite recursion.
Here's how I define plus.
Basically, I said that x+ is defined as x followed by x*,
and the x* is in turn defined in terms of x+.
The problem was that I was going through and saying, okay,
for x when I'm doing plus(opt(a)), for my x I want to choose opt(a).
Okay, I think I'll choose the empty string.
So I chose that, and now I'm left in a recursion
where I have an x*, which is defined in terms of x+,
and I haven't made any progress.
I have a recursive call that's defined in terms of itself.
We know in order to make sure that a recursion terminates,
we have to have some induction where we're reducing something.
It makes sense here that what we're going to reduce is our set Ns.
One way to guarantee to do that is to say
when I'm generating the x followed by the x*
let's make sure that the x generates at least 1 character.
If we can guarantee that x generates a character,
then when we go to do the x* we've reduced our input.
So we have this inductive property saying that now our set of Ns will be smaller.
It's smaller by 1 each time, and if it started out finite and we reduce by 1 every time,
then eventually we're going to terminate.
Let's see how we can implement that idea of saying
every time we have an x+ we have a x and an x*,
we have to choose at least 1 character for x.
Note that that's not limiting us in any way.
That hasn't stopped us from generating all possible expressions,
because if we were going to generate something,
it would have to come from somewhere--either from this x or this x--
and we might as well make sure it comes from here
rather than adding an infinite number of nothings before we generate something.